how's it going everybody last day last
hours chatbots it's gonna get real
pretty fast here no this is a very
introductory look at what it takes to
build chat BOTS some of the technology
that exists out there currently to make
it as easy as possible how you can do
this in Python by yourself and then my
attempt at doing this to help automate
part of my job a quick outline we'll do
some background on me my motivation
types of bots these bot development kits
that have increased in popularity in the
last six to nine months kind of a
build-your-own bot framework with a
little toy example of an airline bot and
then finally mal bot my Frankenstein
monster chat pod that I built to answer
questions about malware the reason why I
built one about malware is because
that's what I do on a day to day basis
I'm a data scientist at endgame it's a
local company in Arlington focused on
information security and hunting out
adversaries crusher network my
particular project is malware
classification very very simple in
theory concept of just supervised
learning good bad what a piece of
software comes in we pull apart some
features about structure of the binary
strings entropy encryption and then
produce a goodness or badness score
associated with and then the other thing
that I'm currently focused on is
providing contextual understanding once
you get that score back for a piece of
software on why is it good or bad that
doesn't really help anybody other than
saying like oh this is bad software not
why is it bad so I take kind of these
really binary level features or byte
level features and then switch that into
a natural language statement this
malware was classified is bad because it
encrypts all your files that's pretty
bad
some things I like one
is being a dad which is really new and
that's the reason for the bags under my
eyes right now sleep training is not
very fun at all
playing watching soccer huge Liverpool
fan anybody out here who's for Chelsea
we're no longer friends
and then finally travelling at the end
of the month I go to Vienna for a a I
conference where I have a paper that got
accepted to CCS on adversarial machine
learning this is much simpler to talk
about which is why I'm very excited to
do it some motivation part of my
background and responsibility day-to-day
is not only understanding the amount
where that comes in and out of these
models but also when the model is
produced why is it producing mistakes
good bad false positives false negatives
it happens it's really embarrassing the
engineers give us a hard time about it
but it's a pretty tough problem to
tackle so what I do is I take those
samples and I all I have is the binary
and then it's file name file name in
this case it's just the sha-256 which is
a new unique representation of a file
what I do then is I run a series of
queries against knowledge bases that we
have at our disposal
I look up things on virustotal which is
a Google run platform that provides a
bunch of information and then after yeah
five or ten questions that I kind of
work through I have a good idea of well
this was a false positive because of X
this was a false negative because of Y
after a while twenty or thirty times
doing this and like my god I cannot do
this for the next nine months as we
continue to roll out production models
so let's try automated automated it it
was working great but it was still a lot
of data just get through each sample was
producing a couple pages of text and lo
and behold Twitter kind of just provided
the answer with all these rise of chat
bot posts there were posts every day on
VentureBeat three or four times a day on
TechCrunch CNN the Washington Post had
an article about why you should care
about chat BOTS and
I guess I should probably care about
chaplains it's the moral of the story so
I just thought I was gonna build one and
had grand visions of building like
Jarvis 2.0 from Ironman put it in the
back of my mind was oh god I'm gonna
create Clippy 2.0 and everybody will
hate me so setting those expectations
became paramount moving forward so the
first thing I did was try to identify
what our chat BOTS or BOTS at their core
they're just automated assistants that
uh mimic human understanding by
accepting an input producing an action
from that input and then providing a
natural language response hence the
title illusion illusion of intelligence
because there's very very little
intelligence actually baked into these
so other than blog hits what are some
other reasons why this bot revolution is
actually occurring this part for me
personally was was by far the most
fascinating to understand just from the
tech field just how fast things are
moving so nine months ago twelve months
ago being an app developer developer was
like the coolest job ever because you
heard people like fourteen-year-old kids
making a game and then becoming like
millionaires and then I was just trying
to figure out why malware was bad seemed
like a very terrible life decision on my
part but then what happened was Google
Play and the Apple App Store they kind
of suck from a UI standpoint and when
you go there you see the same 20 apps
day in and day out so all these other
app developers that were working
feverishly to create awesome products
we're getting buried and the only way
you could find them is if you were alive
and using the Internet and the 90s that
knew how to work like Yahoo's category
because you just have to go category
subcategory sub subcategory and be like
oh well there's the United Airlines app
that's exactly where I expected it to be
and on top of that there was this whole
advent of messenger kik telegram and all
these messaging platforms I'm in my 30s
I don't use messaging platforms a whole
lot but for some reason my mom in
my dad and all of my students family
tend to use it as well as teens so the
app developers were like well
everybody's hanging out in these
messenger platforms now why don't we try
to push our data there create very basic
BOTS to get our information out and when
I say basic I mean absolutely basic CNN
has a chat bot if you could call it that
it just says hey CNN give me the news
and then they send you the news it is
like the most basic thing you can do but
if you're spending all your time on this
app and you don't want to switch you
don't want to jump on the CNN app or
open up Safari and then type in cnn.com
this is fine and you get just they don't
provide the full article so you can you
can narrow it down it starts to learn
your behavior for me it was a lot of
political stuff until I got really sick
of the political stuff and then it
shifted over to just sports and my life
became way easier but yeah super easy
the other big thing is just sometimes
chatting or conversing is it's easier
this if anybody orders pizza a lot can
probably guess the company here but this
is a click-through UI on a website
versus just pizza by the hypothetical or
all-time great pizza bot here you have
in the click-through delivery pickup
size sauce sauce amount toppings
toppings amount filling information
credit card information user name
password all of this stuff but if I go
into messenger where my identity is
stored and my billing information credit
cards stored I can be like yo pizza bot
it's Pizza time
cheese medium the usual place and then
it's done like five seconds a couple of
text messages and you've completely
eliminated the need for this clunky UI I
apologize to anybody who builds you eyes
but sometimes they're just not ideal so
you get in situations like this where it
becomes like oh this is pretty obvious
why this would work out we ordered pizza
like this before using a telephone I
don't know who does that anymore but if
you do that's awesome
so we'll take a little bit more
to the types of bots just to give you
some background as we move into the
bottling kits
the first step is generative versus
retrieval these are like the two highest
levels of BOTS generative is kind of the
the dream which is everything stochastic
it receives an input and generates a
completely novel output you can think of
ex machina or her is the examples of
something like this
not a lot of real-world ones yet and
then retrieval based is something that I
would just say is more doable its
rule-based
even if it uses machine learning it's
still super straightforward it takes an
input creates a feature vector
classifies it and then produces an
output based off some sort of label API
mechanism open domain closed domain is
way too obvious for the amount of bullet
points that I have there but open domain
means you can talk to this spot about
anything ciri Alexa closed domain is
something much more limited in scope you
reduce the amount of inputs and outputs
that you can take everybody in here
would probably if they ever wanted to
build a bot for their company would be
in the close domain circuit because
there would be very specific vocabulary
or domain knowledge you would pass to
that but actually there's a there's a
guy in here Anthony right there who
would probably build a closed domain bot
because he works for city government and
regulation or regulatory data is all
highly structured but very vocabulary
specific so you would just focus on that
it's much easier problem to solve
finally long versus short conversation
long conversation requires some
semblance of intelligence in the fact
that the bot kind of has to keep track
of conversation it's it's keeping state
it understands what you're asking for
and why but it also in the background
knows it needs to extract a series of
parameters or entities if you will in
order to complete its job a good example
would be troubleshooting or reservation
booking if I want to make a reservation
for something I can't just say I need
a reservation I need to provide way more
data in the bot knowing that if you
don't provide it right away we'll steer
the conversation until it grabs all that
short conversation is much easier
it's Siri it's any sort of QA bot what's
the weather in San Diego it's
significantly better than Washington DC
something like that and then this is not
really a type of but but more of just an
example good versus bad BOTS yeah this
is good because I'm like well do I have
to explain Taiba to anybody
no I get this I think you please come
back
all right this is fine it's just
pennants were about to talk crap about
Microsoft I'm sure okay water in this
hand will not put it down the rest of
the time channel my Marco Rubio hear
some good BOTS
yeah good BOTS do not pay has anybody
heard about that do not pay but it's
kind of a really cool idea where if you
live in Seattle London or New York and
you get a parking ticket this spot was
created by like an 18 year old kid at
Stanford will walk you through parking
ticket law which I it's probably a huge
area of interest for some lawyer will
walk you through and then say like
here's what you need to do to fight this
and it's been wildly successful it's
like fought and won two hundred thousand
cases already in like 18 months esther
bot which is another really really cool
idea
this woman Esther created a bot of her
LinkedIn profile so she wouldn't have to
talk to recruiters anymore which is
brilliant so she sits it on LinkedIn and
then the recruiter talks to this but
thinking that it's her about her
background what she wants to do salary
requirements whatever and then if she
gets interested then she drags herself
into the conversation and then the
infamous bad bot hey bud I wanted to
have some screenshots but they were all
so inappropriate that I felt guilty even
putting them on there great idea
like let's put a bot out there and let
the world educated but the world is it
exists on the internet it's pretty
terrible so this went from being a great
idea to a bad idea in the span of like
two hours and was so corrupted and
polluted and said some of the most
inappropriate stuff probably ever
uttered outside a fortune it's yeah yeah
so that got shut down very very quickly
but it was an interesting exercise and
how you can take online learning and
manipulate it for whatever and you want
so out of these which is the best
generative would obviously be the best
if we could get to that point just not
possible right now
a dataset standpoint even from a
training standpoint it would take
sometimes it takes months to generate
like a movie quote but retrieval very
simple small datasets closed domain
there's no grammar mistakes unless
you're not very good at grammar and yeah
it works best in closed domain
situations so this is what will
ultimately focus on because of BOTS
development kits there's been an influx
of companies they all have super trendy
AI domain names which I'm constantly
envious of chat fuel wits API AI they
provide a simple user interface to build
closed domain short conversation
goal-oriented BOTS that's that's a bread
and butter they've gotten so popular
that they've been purchased by some of
the big boys Facebook bought wit last
year by pure happenstance Google by API
AI like two weeks ago when I was making
this slide and then Microsoft Amazon are
creating their own bot development kits
because they have platforms to service
them so they want to try to get
developers in there the same way the App
Store and Google Play did five six years
ago in the architecture that these
things is extremely simplistic it's a
hybrid of rule-based and machine
learning it depends on the amount of
data that you have at your disposal to
train on but all the ML and NLP related
work is completely behind the scenes
like the user has no idea they're just
pointing clicking throwing some data up
and then they hit a train button and
then their bot just starts working so
it's super nice for for people who work
in like the social media managers and
and things like that within companies
you don't need to hire a software
developer to build these things the
framework that you are responsible for
providing is something like this on the
right which is just a flow diagram
decision tree in this case it's like
1-800 flowers I think where each
question you just move along and kind of
a choose-your-own-adventure you have a
task or an action that you're trying to
carry out and that's just buy some
flowers so how do you go from hello to
you just bought flowers that's all you
have to think about
and the way you do this is by following
this sort of workflow the bot
development kits more or less help you
with session which is just when the user
starts interacting with the bot it locks
you into a session logs everything
everything's associated one user
identity we touched upon which is just
capturing your persona and making it
accessible to the bot billing
information credit card information
whatever and then the dialogue script is
really the the beginning point of where
you're interacting and providing context
to the bot context and intent are really
the two I guess core buzzwords that
you'll hear a lot of times with bot
development kits we're just building
chat BOTS in general context all that's
doing is that's your little manager he's
there just watching the conversation
understanding what all needs to happen
and ensuring that you are hitting every
step of the way in order for the bot to
carry out the task intense all that's
doing is taking a user input and then
the intent is just the label that the
little text based classifier comes up
with to move you down the line and
within those intents there are sometimes
entities entities from anybody who
understands or knows NLP are just
parameters
they're usually proper nouns city states
pizza toppings anything like that all
you're doing is you're providing a list
of these entities that's like well once
you identify what the user wants now we
have to figure out what exactly they're
trying to get out of it so in the flower
example you know the entities are types
of flowers you can create permutations
just so you can handle some diversity in
language I think this is what he I they
got kind of lazy by just making it
plural as your options of growing your
data set you could do other things too
that we'll get into a little bit later
training data is is kind of the biggest
one that presumably would scare people
off certainly certainly put me off a
little bit as well how do you build
something
it can be robust enough to handle a
regular human being entering in a string
of text and then understanding it when
you have like five examples of what that
person could potentially say with the
bot development community does is they
have predefined domains and knowledge
packages so believe it or not that pizza
bot example was one of like 300 Pizza
BOTS so when you have 300 Pizza BOTS and
300 thousand users talking to a pizza
bot every day your dataset starts to
grow quite a bit and that dataset isn't
just tied to Domino's or Papa John's or
Little Caesars to be used by anybody so
these these companies collect all of
that data and they kind of anonymize it
and then they make it available to the
next person creating their bot saying
hey you have like five good examples how
would you like 300 thousand and the
answer to that should always be yes
please let's make that happen
additionally you'll provide common
intentions or entities so pizza but
they're gonna give you all your toppings
you don't have to type that out but give
you the option to add in as you see fit
so natural language processing machine
learning as I said earlier it's kind of
baked into these platforms very much
behind the scenes but that isn't to say
that they don't do it and don't do it
really really well
the folks if wid AI and API AI were
really good at this for a reason and
they're even more of a reason why
Facebook and Google bought them so if
you want to think about it in context of
a conversation the input hits the NLP
pipeline
to create the features that are fed into
the machine learning algorithm it
classifies the intents that produces the
output when you think about it like that
all of this stuff tokenization synonym
generation all that becomes a way easier
to understand and you start to see like
just because they have AI and their
domain doesn't mean they're doing some
sort of weird creating a fake brain or
anything like that it's all very
standard there's been a ton of talks
even at PI data on this anybody could
apply this but it's all very very easy
to
and like I said it's literally a button
that says train and you have no idea
what it's doing but it does it well and
additionally they another thing that I
personally like is they use models that
can be updated on the fly so SVM's or
naivebayes they do logging so each time
your user interacts with your butt and
you provide an answer you kind of self
participate in active learning so if you
gave a wrong label you correct that
label and then that gets fed back into
the model so the next time you get it
right and there's something to be said
about about that customer service aspect
so how do you do this in python there
are a ton of ways to do this in python
from NLP standpoint you have some great
options spacey text blob parse date/time
NLT k from a machine learning deep
learning standpoint
Kerris psych it tensorflow all of these
can kind of be mashed together in a in a
Frankenstein sort of fashion to create
your own chatbot and as an example we're
gonna create an airfare bot at a very
high level just to give you an idea of
the workflow that I presented a few
slides ago so the airfare bot is gonna
be very very basic it does two things it
will either show you flights or book a
flight for you so once you know that
those are your actions what do you need
in order to successfully do those things
when I'm on kayak and I want to see
flights I just need to provide a kind of
a to and from maybe a date and then I
get results back and then from a book of
flight I need to provide a - from but in
reality it's really a flight number two
flight number from and then a date and
those are the those are the actions
those are the parameters those are the
functions that feed the API that will
produce the results that your chat bot
will spit out so to get those parameters
you'll do entity extraction to extract
from text cities airport codes dates
times
from intense you're gonna have to create
a series of them like show me flights
from A to B are there flights from A to
B can you book flight one two three four
and five six seven eight a bunch of
those and then finally the context kind
of the the playbook for the bots you
have a show flight playbook in a book
flight playbook that's all that's gonna
do is once you enter one context it's
going to head down that path
full speed ahead until it accomplishes
its goal so quick
NLP 101 I don't know maybe it should
just be oh oh one this is a very basic
but we're gonna use spacey if you guys
are familiar with Spacey it's really
really great super intuitive not very
difficult at all and our sentence here
which mimics what a user would
potentially type into about show flights
from Washington to Denver on Monday
we'll break that down we'll tokenize it
and then grab its parts of speech tokens
on the left parts of speech on the right
and the reason why you can do this is
maybe you don't want to use machine
learning at all you could literally just
build a giant different decision tree
if-else statements and parts of speech
will help you with that because things
like show or order have verb and noun
meetings you can go through and be like
well I don't want to go to a show or I
don't want to start a task order like I
want to be able to order a flight or
book a flight so I'm going to look in
that sentence it shows a verb and flight
as a noun which flights you by and large
always be a noun then we call or set the
context show flights then you move them
down to that very very straightforward
and goes from zero understanding to some
very basic natural language
understanding in three lines wordnet is
the better way you can go from those
five pieces of training data to 25 35
100 in this case I just take the text
blog library and feed in the word net
platform I think mighty open NLP and
TK I'll have access to this as well I
take book and then I produce the cin
sets associated to book since that's
synonyms whatever very very
straightforward we see the book is
represented as a noun
way more than I thought was possible and
then we get to the part that we're
interested in which is reserved for
number four arranged for or reserved
something so that looks to be closest to
what we mean for book flight so we can
take that throw it up on the right-hand
side and say give me its base form its
lemma and then once we have the lemma
let's go through and look at the hyper
and hypo names kind of a micro and macro
variants of this word we'll put them all
together into a giant list and then
we'll create a set and we'll get
potentially new data and we do we go
from the word book so now we have
reserved hold request probably not going
to use the speak but maybe if we have
like an old-timey gentleman once
interact with our chat bot keep open
save quest would be another one I might
start doing that when I'm at the airport
quest a flight but but some of this is
obviously gonna require some hand
annotation but if you're thinking about
things and you're like alright I know I
need to accept book flight but people
are never really going to ask other
things this is like a super quick hack
to go from zero to some alternatives
that's all that's all it really is once
you have your entities then you can kind
of move on to intend classification as I
said earlier we could keep this very
straightforward with just regex and a
series of if else statements and make it
the most basic chatbot ever but it'll
crap out after your first user because
nobody uses it the way you would use it
that's what I found out and it gets
annoying very very quickly to explain
that to people but but machine learning
kind of allows you to be fuzzier handle
misspellings using things like engrams
for versus uh or bag-of-words and
treating your intention labels as a
multi-class classification problem
use an SVM now you've based something
that can update each time you get a new
data point and a label and we can take
our very toy data set here of types of
utterances that could come from a user
and then the context that that would
likely mean we pass that into sight it's
tf-idf vectorizer and we break it down
between two and three engrams
transform that into our feature vector
to then train on a linear SVM and that
we have our statement that we've been
using throughout Show flights from
Washington to Denver on Monday we
classify it we get the label show flight
and now we know okay show flight require
some entities to be extracted show
flight requires a two from and a date
this is where named entity resolution
comes in handy there's definitely been a
talk on this already so I'm just gonna
gloss glide over it named entity just
breaks sentences down into noun chunks
and then tries to derive whether or not
any of the points within those chunks
are proper nouns companies dates
locations names anything like that so
we'll use polyglot I don't know if
people know this I found it the other
day and it was way easier than open NLP
but I would never tweet that I guess
open NLP is very active on Twitter but
yeah very straightforward three lines
and I go from like having no natural
language understanding about a sentence
to grabbing the things that I need
that's awesome but I still have some
trouble with the word Monday parts day
time is an alternative to named entity
resolution but specifically for dates
and times it's a very clever name you do
the same thing you basically pass that
blob you parse it and then you're able
to extract things like month date hour
whatever so they're able to interpret
Monday and then give back to me oh well
based off with the day that yes that
Monday for me are my understanding is
October 10th 2016 so at that point I
have everything that I need
I can go out reach out into the database
pull down fly
it's and present that back to the user
and then that is airfare bot feel free
to create that at your earliest
convenience so the last area is mal baat
mal but as I said was just really kind
of a hacky way for me to get out of
doing some of the the day-to-day grind
involved with analyzing malware some of
the reasons why something they go awry
on the model its retrieval based it's
even easier than the the airfare bot in
the sense that it's just strictly QA
there's nothing really more advanced to
it than that
I had it mapped to like 9 or 10 intense
those nine of them involved the
questions that I normally ask a piece of
software when trying to figure out what
went wrong and then one intent was just
to handle unknown things so if anybody
else used it it would be able to
redirect them down to hey you messed up
you can't ask me like why are we alive
I'm going to steer you why don't you ask
about section entropy that's way cooler
and something that I can answer so the
questions I generated were the same way
that I generated them for the air fare
bot it was I had five or ten examples
for each one and then I started using
lemmas and hyper names - M's
and grew that set out to a more
respectable like 100 lines and then with
the addition of logging adding logging
in and I was able to grab from my
colleagues how they were questioning
things and that more or less replicated
my beginning and end to analyzing false
positives and false negatives and it was
great I build it using a way too
complicated
caris model because I thought I was
being super clever and then I realized
that I actually got way better
performance with just a linear SVM but I
felt obligated to leave Kerris in there
because it was in my description for
this talk
delivering on promises never say I
didn't do that
so what are we looking at from an
architecture standpoint we kind of saw
some examples on how to do this in
Python but how does this all actually
scale out the easiest way to describe
this is we start with the user utterance
or user input and then what I'm
constantly doing or what Melba is
constantly doing is it needs to know
what it's talking about
did you can't just jump in and start
talking about malware because he has no
context so the first thing he does is
each time you enter in a statement he is
looking for a shot to 56 that is my one
entity that I'm looking for which is
lucky because creating regex define
shotgun six is super straightforward if
he finds a shot 256
he then loads everything from our
malware knowledgebase on that sample
into memory and then you can begin query
in him or interrogating him or however
you want to capture so once that's ready
a statement comes back out it says
something like my persona has been
uploaded please ask me questions and
then the user knows okay I can start
asking questions about this sample so at
that point each question that comes in
its tokenized and broken down into
features classified and intent label was
created that label maps to a an API that
maps directly to the malware knowledge
base and then I did this kind of hacky
Madalyn sort of thing that you see down
there where the intent label is like
entropy API
so when entry and Trippi API hits I can
query directly with entropy API into the
our knowledge base grab that data out
and then do a print format or or a
string replace for entropy API with the
actual data so then it says I have high
entropy so there's the illusion of
intelligence keep going back to the
title because that would be the clever
thing to do
additionally I mean it's the same thing
name sections imports exports all of
that it made it very very easy to upload
new intents
to handle any sort of conflict
management between like
misunderstandings of user inputs adding
a logging module became important
because like I said I wanted to continue
to grow that data set and understand why
my users or other teammates we're
querying this this piece of software in
the way of the way they were and I made
it all available on an internal HipChat
server because that's where we have
access to the bulk of our data so
architecture considerations I've more or
less touched on a lot of these context
management is by far the most important
thing because that just allows the user
and the bot itself to be on the same
playing field know what they're talking
about
I added short-term memory because I
worked for a cyber security company and
they like to break everything even
heartless entities like malware bot came
under duress almost immediately
so I created short-term memory to
basically say if you're gonna keep
asking the same question I'm going to
direct you to something else so he has
like a little stack that he has where he
remembers what he has said previously
and what the users said previously and
if it hits on any of those then he calls
you out and then we do some hip chat
shaming which is clever and then logging
was the other core component that was
very easy to implant just using the
Python standard logging library so this
is what he looks like it's not great but
this is the only way I can get it helps
of our network are you going to see
there yeah how about saving into the
wild
you start out everything is two slash
come in if you guys have hit chat or
slack or anything like
it's it's pretty standard fare on how
you interacted from bots in messaging
platforms / email by sha-256 he comes
back saying I processed this I'm good to
go start asking questions what is your
name he provides a list of names that he
has been called according to Iris Koval
I can distill down when were you
compiled what functions do you import do
high entropy and then all the sudden I
want to switch to a new sample I pass a
new sha he immediately forgets what he
was talking about switch is over and you
start the conversation again this got a
little bit more complicated when more
people get involved because I'm you're
saving context and state for multiple
users the easiest way to do that at
least in HipChat which is kind of a
nested dictionary it took about 30
minutes to implement but wasn't too bad
all things considered yeah so Mel but
right there in all of its glory
so something's left but I want to do
just to make it a little bit more robust
and practice what I preach on some of
these other slides this starts at handle
yes and no questions because yes or no
questions are surprisingly difficult if
you guys have looked at the Facebook
babby
data set it's very very cool but they
talk about the same thing it's would you
like to see more functions and then the
user says yes and then you have to
remember that you just asked it would
you like to look at more functions yes
seems totally easy until you're
programming it and then it is a complete
nightmare
likewise with an idiot raction because I
don't work in a domain as like pizza
toppings which would be really nice or
like city codes
I have things like kernel32.dll can I
build an entity extractor custom for my
domain and this is something that I
think a lot of people are probably in
here would have to deal with - Anthony
with like government regulation data
medical data legal data there there
aren't entity extractors really for that
so how do you create your own so you can
allow more targeted queries to occur
show me imported functions from kernel32
that's a much harder problem to solve
but probably a much more fun problem
solve and then finally what do you do
when your user is just incapable of
hitting any question that your bot
actually knows how to answer which was
amazing to see we launched our bot and
in within like two hours I just had
people coming up and being like why
can't I ask it this so I can ask this
and I'm like well you know it's a
project that I was doing for PI data
wasn't supposed to be anything other
than that I don't know I uploaded it and
let all of you use it this is just a
terrible terrible idea so the next thing
is like oh and you asked a question and
I don't know I'm going to steer you into
saying like hey I actually don't know
this but why don't you ask me one of
these I feel like it could turn into
like Kramer with Moviefone if you guys
remember that sign home why don't you
just tell me what you want asked we'll
get there but anyway yeah so that is
that is mal BOTS I put together a little
list of resources to kind of get you
going both from the bot development side
and just general BOTS resources brand
new field even though they've been
around since the 70s it's a new field
and it's very fun to work on and there's
potential there to help automate your
your day to day job questions
always refused what's that
yeah I'll push them a SlideShare or
something
definitely cool all right thanks guys